okay this is sort of funny and it's also
very very depressing at a recent
fundraiser Democratic candidate and
former Barack Obama Vice President Joe
Biden made some promises to wealthy
donors including that he won't quote
demonize them and that nothing big will
change for them if he becomes president
of the United States and my reaction was
yeah Joe we know that I don't think you
had to say that we know that Joe Biden
basically saying the quiet part out loud
making clear that his politics are
politics of centrist status quo
center-left ISM and we knew that right
here is a list of what Joe Biden had to
say just a couple of days ago to a group
of rich donors in New York City Joe
Biden told them I need you very badly
Joe Biden told these wealthy
contributors in New York City no one's
standard of living will change nothing
would fundamentally change Joe Biden
said that rich people are quote just as
patriotic as poor people Joe Biden said
quote we may not want to demonize
anybody who has made money and Joe Biden
said I hope if I win this nomination I
won't let you down meaning you rich
people who are giving me money we know
Joe we know this is this is actually
great in a sense this is confirmation
about exactly what we will get with Joe
Biden we knew that Joe Biden was the
status quo economic policy with some
slight leftward moves combined with
moderately left social policy that's
what we could expect from Joe Biden and
he's confirming it here this idea of
nothing will fundamentally change
that's literally status quo centrism
it's I'm basically in the middle and
slightly to the left on on social policy
and I'll make some tweaks on economic
policy but nothing is substance abstain
JH he needs the rich donors he's not
going to do anything that's going to be
scary to them and he's telling them I'm
safe for you I will say stuff on the
campaign trail about economic justice
and inequality and paying people's fair
share in all of this stuff but that big
picture he'll work around the edges and
he's not going to substantively change
for them other than playing at the
margins a little bit so this is the
exact opposite of change you can believe
in it's no change and you can be sure of
it and you can safely vote for me
without worrying that I'm going to take
too much of your money he's saying there
will be some cake crumbs for the middle
class of the poor sprinkled on them but
that big picture the rich are going to
keep their full rich decadent black
forest chocolate cakes or whatever
analogy or metaphor you want to apply
here this is like a really memorable non
story of the campaign in the sense that
we knew that this was why Joe Biden was
the safest ab lachemann candidate he
will say mostly the right things in
public on policy now he has gaffes
obviously but he is going to be
completely predictable in his governance
there is not going to be anything
earth-shaking that will happen and in a
sense this is very similar to what we
expected with Hillary Clinton when I've
said that a Hillary Clinton presidency
would have been boring in a sense it's
because she would have been predictably
center-left we would have as a
progressive show critiqued her from
further to her left she wouldn't have
done anything that would have generated
the worldwide cartoonish embarrassment
that Donald Trump has generated but it
would have been all of the expected
stuff there would have been some crumbs
for the lower in middle class and there
would have been status quo center-left
foreign policy period big picture and
Joe Biden is effectively the same as far
as that goes we know what we get with
him and in a sense I think it's a good
thing that this is now out in the open
the contrast between Joe Biden and
people like Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren is now much more clear vote for
what you want and it's now really clear
what it is that each candidate is
offering I actually I've said before I
don't really understand undecided voters
two months or a month before the
election once we've had the debates and
once we've had the primaries I really
don't understand how someone could be
undecided at that point in time because
it's so clear how different whatever can
that it's remain are at that point and
even when you look at Hillary and Trump
very very different I know Hilary is a
center-left Democrat but very different
than Donald Trump and I didn't
understand how someone could be
undecided a few weeks before the
election in 2016 as people would call in
and tell me that they were right now I
understand saying you know I'm on the
progressive wing so for me it could be
warned it could be Bernie it could be
somebody else if they end up being the
nominee and if it's Biden I'm gonna vote
for him because he's better than Trump
right like it's super clear to me at
this point sort of how someone might be
in that mode but what at this point is
really great that has come from these
revelations from Joe Biden in private is
that there is no more question about
what a Joe Biden presidency would be if
you had any question remaining which
many of us who follow this stuff didn't
safe for very rich people crumbs for the
lower and middle classes and a
center-left foreign policy that's what
we can expect and it's abundantly clear
and now we can all support the candidate
that we believe most aligns with our
values I want to hear from you what do
you make of these statements by Joe
Biden in private although we now know
what was said to very wealthy donors in
New York City I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
follow me let me know what you think and
while you're there follow the show on
Twitter as well at David Pakman show
you're always searching for ways to
transform your life into one that's
smarter richer more connected with your
world and at Excelsior dot edu they
believe nothing is more transformative
than education and for nearly 50 years
Excelsior College a fully accredited
nonprofit leader in online education has
been helping adult students complete
their college degrees achieve their
career goals offering career focused
programs in Health Sciences nursing
cybersecurity criminal justice business
and more that enable students to advance
their careers or find employment in high
demand fields Excelsior's online classes
give you the flexibility to earn your
degree on your time wherever you are in
addition to world class challenging
coursework excelsior offers a generous
credit transfer policy and is dedicated
to student support whether your goal is
building
business leading a team or helping
others there is a degree to help you get
there you'll build on the experience you
already have to develop new skills forge
new connections gain the knowledge you
need to take that next steps
check out Excelsior dot edu slash keep
learning to learn more